bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 7 juin vous
regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de nous
retrouver comme chaque jour nous là nous
allons revenir sur les principales
informations qui font l'actualité
aujourd'hui avec nos invités mais
également avec les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite et les titres
que nous allons développer c'est dans
cette émission
aujourd'hui le pôle de compétitivité en
recherche et développement mobilité
automobile mauvais organise le mot vod à
l'école d'ingénieurs estaca de montigny
le bretonneux
tour d'horizon des innovations de ce
secteur bientôt disponible pour le grand
public
et comme chaque année des milliers de
jeunes lycéens se prépare à passer le
baccalauréat plus qu'une semaine avant
les premières épreuves nous avons suivi
deux d'entre eux de jeunes dans leurs
révisions et gimont iii avant le début
de l'euro 2016 versailles et le camp de
base de l'équipe d'irlande pour
l'occasion toute la ville se mobilise
même dans les écoles au collège carnot
par exemple l'irlande est plus que
jamais au programme et pour ouvrir ce
journal un mot de politique la primaire
à droite aura lieu en novembre 2016 et
les candidats multiplient les actions et
réunion pour se distinguer je le
rappelle ils sont douze candidats a
déclaré lire c'est le programme de
françois fillon qui étaient expliquées
dans la salle paul gauguin de montigny
le bretonneux
l'objet de la rencontre portait sur le
volet sont est une thématique peut
aborder jusqu'à là dans cette primaire
bernard debré ancien ministre actuel
député de paris mais aussi chirurgien et
le porte parole du candidat pour la
santé dans les yvelines la santé en
france
une problématique à laquelle il faut
s'intéresser avant que la situation ne
se dégrade trop selon lui a coûté le et
lé vrai problème et puis les problèmes
aussi d'accessibilité pour les français
et les françaises ont poney ccc
traquèrent
on sait que choisir un médecin c'est pas
si simple demander un rendez-vous
d'ophtalmologie ça peut prendre trois
mois ou six mois en neuf mois il ya un
vrai problème et nous sommes en train
d'essayer de proposer un certain nombre
de solutions et nous sommes aussi l
écoute des uns des autres parce qu'on
n'a pas la parole révélée
on a beaucoup travaillé depuis longtemps
mais on est là aussi pour écouter les
questions d'essayer dé répondre mais
aussi écouter leurs propositions
innovation à présent l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
recevait aujourd'hui les mauvais au day
le rendez vous des acteurs innovants de
l'industrie de l'automobile et du
transport dont le cheval de bataille et
de développer la mobilité propre sûr et
intelligente de demain retour sur les
dernières innovations avec fanny
bourdillon et cathy le moal pas facile
de l'apprivoiser et pourtant ce gyropode
pourrait être le véhicule de demain
nommé hub l'ex il a demandé cinq ans de
recherche et développement aujourd'hui
c'est le grand jour pour ses fondateurs
ils sont venus le présenter au mauvais
au days journées de la mobilité du futur
à l'estaca est donc ce véhicule permet
en fait d équivalent à la marche à pied
donc on peut faire du demi tour sur
saône et on peut atteindre une vitesse
de 10 km h un véhicule électrique pour
les professionnels qui souhaitent se
déplacer en intérieur hubley hx7
aujourd'hui une start up de cette
personne pour cette équipe
les mauvais au day c'est surtout
l'occasion de mettre en avant leurs
innovations
c'est ne plus de visibilité vis-à-vis
d'un industriel qui pourrait être soit
nos futurs collaborateurs soient nos
futurs clients
parce que ben des gens comme psa ou
renault ont des grands sites industriels
soit qu'elle peut utiliser gyropode mais
aussi des compétences avec laquelle on
pourrait travailler dans le futur pour
développer de nouveaux véhicules
autre innovation automobile le véhicule
instrumenté véritable laboratoire mobile
ce modèle doté de 300 capteur permet de
recueillir des données comme les
comportement du conducteur et son
environnement
il a été conçu par la start-up
yvelinoise à dax s c'est notre premier
véhicule 100 % instrumenté donc on a
choisi un modèle aurait donc avant
kühl électrique donc il est instrumenté
avait près de 300 capteurs dans le
véhicule
intégré à la fois sous le capot mais
aussi dans toute la partie power trip du
véhicule est donc l'objectif c'est de
créer ou en tout cas de générer des
données le données qualifiées ensuite on
travaille directement dans nos bureaux
pour nos clients pour deux projets
ensuite que ce soit des projets de
développement innovation encore une fois
pour addax est ce l'enjeu des mauvais au
days c'est aussi les imagine mobility
awards un titre important qui récompense
chaque année la mobilité intelligente et
connecté ou encore les véhicules propres
et économes et justement nous venons à
de l'apprendre la start-up que vous
venez de voir à d'access deux fois ci
vient de report remporter le fameux
mobility award dans la catégorie propres
et économes passons maintenant aux
sports plus que trois jours à attendre
avant le début de l'euro 2016 vous le
savez la vie
la ville de versailles s'apprête à
accueillir l'équipe d'irlande de
république d'irlande une classe du
collège carnot a été sélectionné pour
aller rencontrer les joueurs de l'équipe
lors de leur séance de préparation il
rencontre que la professeur a rencontré
en amont avec les élèves en leur faisant
découvrir un pays qu'il ne connaissait
pas pour la plupart un reportage signé
william elles ont créé un nouvel on vous
présentait là maintenant les briques
comme vous le voyez sur la photo il ya
un château fort qui a été construit à
l'époque de jean sans terre
cyclo émana elles expliquent à leurs
camarades la géographie de l'irlande
c'est parce que leur classe a été
sélectionné pour rencontrer l'équipe des
verts lors de leur préparation pour
l'euro 2016
une rencontre que la classe a pris très
au sérieux en étudiant ce pays qu'ils
ont découvert pour la plupart d'entre
eux ça nous a amené à découvrir l'île
ronde était divisé en deux donc ils
connaissaient principalement l'irlande
du nord faisant partie du royaume uni ça
c'est une chose qu'on étudie mais c'est
vrai que l'irlande la république
d'irlande est souvent un peu oublié
laissait de côté donc là ça nous a
permis de faire un
zoom sur ce pays et ils ont découvert
plein de choses et pour comprendre
l'irlande
rien de mieux qu'une véritable
irlandaise pour expliquer les coutumes
et l'histoire du pays c'est comme tous
les enfants et même mes enfants me
demandent c'est nous on avait la
télévision qu'on était jeune donc ça
semble loin tout en louant donc voilà
ils ont besoin d'expérience et de devoir
commencer rien déjà j'ai découvert ont
des traditions hernandez et c est
comment d'irlande du nord et l'irlande
du ver langue et la république d'irlande
ceei tc paris
ça m'a beaucoup plu parce que c'est un
beau pays et cultures sont d'elle et je
trouve que l'ami des nappes maîtresse
nous a vraiment très bien représenté le
pays et que mes camarades aussi un pays
qu'ils auront l'honneur d'aller
encourager et même interviewé et pour ça
rien de mieux que d'apprendre le fameux
cri de guerre est demandé et il devait
arriver aujourd'hui les joueurs de la
sélection irlandaise était attendu cet
après midi à versailles comme vous le
voyez sur les images leur bus étaient là
mais ce n'était qu'une répétition les
hommes de martin o'neill sélectionneur
de la république d'irlande devrait
arriver demain dans la cité royale les
boys in green sont dans le groupe e avec
l'italie la suède et la belgique
ceux qui font office de petit poucet
dans ce groupe feront leur entrée dans
le tournoi le 13 juin à 18 heures au
stade de france face à la suède de
zlatan ibrahimovic et une journée de
golf pour les écoliers yvelinois près de
300 élèves de 13 écoles des yvelines
inscrit à la fête du golfe ce lundi 6
juin sur le site national de bulle en
cours encadrés par des golfeurs
professionnels les enfants ont aussi
participé à des démonstrations
événement met en oeuvre par la
fédération française de golf et
l'académie de verser à seulement deux
ans de la ryder cup est organisée sur ce
green promotion de la discipline
nouvelle méthode pédagogique faisant
partie des objectifs de ce rendez vous
et c'est aussi une activité d'éducation
physique et sportive une d apprentissage
des règles et puis apprendre à
travailler en équipe à travers apprendre
la bienveillance le but est de d'allier
la pratique du golf en tant que sport
avec les matières enseignées en cm1 cm2
et sensibiliser aussi les enfants un
environnement écologique développement
durable par la pratique d'un sport
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique ce soir c'est william elle qui
est avec nous en plateau alors pour
parler de prévention contre le sida mais
aussi de musique tout à fait alors
plutôt d'un festival qui regroupe
prévention et musique je veux bien
entendu parler de solidays de
l'événement de solidarité sida qui
devenu maintenant incontournable en
ile-de-france un festival dont
l'objectif est la récolte de fonds pour
la lutte contre le sida comme l'année
dernière ça se passera à l'hippodrome de
longchamp du 24 au 26 juin
il y aura plus de 80 concerts avec des
têtes d'affiché comme oxmo puccino
qu'oxmo puccino keziah jones
ibrahim maalouf cypress hill ou encore
louise attaque jeudi dernier nous étions
à la conférence de presse du lancement
de l'événement qui cette année prend le
nom de solidays of love qui s'inspirent
du mouvement américain summer of love
est séduite d'avouer leur dis de
directeur qui nous explique pourquoi
c'est un mouvement né de la jeunesse
dans les années 65 1967 qui né à san
francisco et en gros c'était un
mouvement pacifique pacifiste il ya eu
une dizaine de jeunes des dizaines de
jeunes des centaines des milliers d a
dominé des centaines de milliers qui ont
demandé la fin de la guerre au vietnam
et qui ont deux
demander la fin de la discrimination
entre noirs et blancs et donc voilà ça
débouchait sur un mouvement sociétal qui
a dépassé tout le monde même les médias
et donc notre liste est d'essayer de
faire un parallèle entre le mouvement de
jeunesse de san francisco donc le
festival ici dépasse le cadre de la
lutte juste contre le sida
oui justement même si cette lutte reste
la vocation première est la raison pour
laquelle les artistes se mobilisent
pendant ces trois jours solidays est un
festival qui se veut humaniste et comme
l'a dit son directeur et fondateur qui
traite de plusieurs sujets de société on
le voit avec les artistes invités qui ne
sont pas tous des chanteurs l'année
dernière yann arthus-bertrand présenter
son film human en projection au festival
cette année c'est le photoreportage qui
est à l'honneur avec la présence de deux
expositions la première c'est celle de
résa conçu spécialement pour solidays et
la seconde c'est celle de dan ar qui est
actuellement en exposition au palais de
tokyo
il traite évidemment de thèmes
d'actualité son exposition s'intitule à
jan willem et a pour but de redonner une
identité aux réfugiés dont elle a suivi
le parcours de lesbos à munich en les
photographiant nous l'avons rencontrée
et elle nous en parle c'est des gens qui
ne peuvent pas faire machine arrière et
donc il raconte le possible d'un
ailleurs mais aussi il raconte le
possible avec nous je suis très fier que
bouchra naouar ali farid mohamed est là
zahara soit debout dans les solidays et
qu'au moment où
on célèbre l'engagement le vivre
ensemble que ya toujours un coin de
notre cerveau et de notre regard qui
fait qu'on les regarde quoi donc soleil
c'est clairement un festival engagé
oui c'est un festival qui s'engagent
surtout il ne faut pas oublier que
l'objectif c'est surtout de récolter des
fonds pour la lutte contre le sida
le festival a donc fait une grande place
à la prévention en invitant de
nombreuses associations comme hf
prévention que nous conte que nous
connaissons bien un téléfilm et qui sera
sur place pendant trois jours pour l'ubs
avril le directeur
cette année est aussi une année très
importante car la france va devoir se
prononcer sur le montant de sa
contribution au fonds mondial en fonds
mondial de lutte contre le sida
une contribution qui va être impactée
par les recettes du festival qui
continue qui se constitue une aide
majeure pardon pour ce fonds solidays un
festival qui ne pourraient également pas
existé non plus sans l'aide des
bénévoles ils sont plus de 3000 chaque
année à prendre de leur temps pour venir
installer et organiser l'événement moi
ce que je préfère en fait celle aller
faire ma pub dit au village associatif
parce que où aller dire bonjour aux
bénévoles
tous les gens qu'on bossait sur le
festival ils sont 2000 quand même à nous
permettent de réaliser ce truc là il ya
certains de bénévoles composée trois
semaines de vacances sur le sens qu'ils
ont à l'année pour faire le montage
démontage d'exploitation ils viennent de
la france entière voilà moi j'ai un
profond respect pour eux et je pense que
cette l'esprit si particulier qui règne
à solidays ils ont pour beaucoup parce
qu'ils en sont à la fois les principaux
moteurs et les principaux ambassadeurs
les bénévoles qui sont remerciés chaque
année comme il se doit par les
organisateurs avec une soirée en leur
honneur
mais le festival a également de nombreux
partenaires et la région ile de france
et d'ailleurs le premier partenaire car
le participe à hauteur de 800 1000 euros
chaque année
alors on savait jean paul huchon jean
paul huchon ancien président de la
région grand rockeur est aussi très
attaché au festival la région ayant
changé de gouvernance on a demandé à
valérie pécresse la nouvelle présidente
de région sur quelle scène elle allait
plutôt se rendre au mais moi j'adore
l'électro donc je pense que je suis plus
en phase avec la programmation de
solides et peut-être que mon
prédécesseur parce que le rock c'est
plutôt à saint claud et c'est plutôt
rock en seine voilà alors on a fait un
rapide tour du festival qui sera
d'ailleurs encore plus grand cette année
avec cinq hectares supplémentaires 3
nouvelle cn pour la découverte de
nouveaux artistes et beaucoup d'autres
espaces en plus brefs
solidays un festival qui n'arrête pas
d'évoluer j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
annoncer que terry fils sera là bas le
temps d'un week end pour une émission
spéciale avec jérôme andré directeur de
hf prévention mais aussi de tous les
artistes qu'on pourra croiser d'ailleurs
les artistes on les écoute je suis
engagé en tant qu'artiste parce que
parce qu'on a une voix données et je
suis engagé humainement parce qu'il
s'agit aussi de préserver la vie il
s'agit de promouvoir l'amour est pour
moi le sida est un et en tue l'amour et
donc
nous sommes là pour pour la pole pour le
combattre c'est une affiche qui est qui
qui appelle peace and love
c'est à dire le pouvoir de la fleur et
puis des sourires et finalement c'est ce
qu'on a besoin je crois que depuis cro
magnon jusqu à cosmos 1999 dans l'avenir
c'est ça c'est peace and love donc
évidemment que je que je suis merci
williams alors je le rappelle est solide
et c'est du 24 au 26 juin ou à
l'hippodrome de longchamp vous y
retrouvera est un autre grand rendez
vous approche bons souvenirs il est
moins festif et il est plus redoutée que
l'euro et les solides et c'est bien sûr
le baccalauréat les épreuves écrites
commence le 15 juin prochain avec comme
chaque année l'épreuve de philosophie
pour les filières générales et le
français pour les filières
professionnelles alors l'heure est
aujourd'hui aux révisions bien sûr pour
les 690 mille candidats qui sont
attendus aux épreuves de terminale nous
en avons rencontré deux d'entre eux
pendant leurs révisions
regardez ce reportage florian 17 ans
prépare un bac général scientifique
à deux semaines de la première épreuve
il est en pleine révision
j'étais défait repos par semaine je mets
plusieurs matches dans la semaine et je
me tiens à ce que je fais des fils de
révision a partout des chapitres est
donc comme ça je voulais les fiches de
révision mais ça rentre en tête après
chaque session de révision il n'oublie
pas de se détendre et va jouer au foot
entre copains ou avec son club l'étoile
sportive de trappes à la part du temps
quand je rentre des cours je mange un
tuteur révise le plus possible avant le
foot
ensuite j'ai moins traîner si en
rentrant j'ai encore un peu de
motivation que le lendemain j'ai une
épreuve important de barils et encore
même rythme pour mamadou 19 ans il
présente un bac professionnel technicien
du froid et du conditionnement de l'air
quand il ne révise pas chez lui
c'est au cap à dos de magny les hameaux
qu'il s'isole avant de rejoindre famille
et amis pour jouer au jeu préféré tout
seul pour être dans le calme pour pour
me sentir un peu seul pour mettre en
retrait un peu un peu et c'est mieux
je sais mieux comme soit aussi d'être
dans le calme depuis j'ai reçu les
convocations du bac j'ai commencé à
réviser et les proches on nous a dit
rossi on va commencer à réviser et quand
j'ai fini mes épreuves d'ateliers et de
maths et de physique j'ai commencé
directement à réviser florian vise la
mention assez bien accessible à partir
d'une moyenne de 12 sur 20 s'il devient
bacheliers mamadou espère entrer en bts
verdict le 5 juillet prochain date des
résultats
l'an dernier près de 88% des candidats
obtenaient le baccalauréat général dans
la filière professionnelle
le taux de réussite était de 91 5% et
les élèves dont nous avons parlé à
présent n'ont pas encore le bac en
revanche ils ont leur permis internet
alors le permis internet c'est un
document qui atteste d'une certaine
connaissance de l'usagé d'internet mais
aussi des réseaux sociaux
vendredi dernier deux classes de cm2 des
longs cours recevait ce fameux permis
mise en place cette année avec deux
agents de la commune c'est un moyen pour
la ville de former et de prévenir les
plus jeunes à la bonne utilisation
d'internet et des réseaux sociaux
un reportage ses emails and i poke et je
sais que je vais pas mettre n'importe
quelle photo qui va me tombait sous la
main je vais je vais choisir enfin voilà
quoi
et puis ici je vais mettre une photo de
mon ami gérer le lendemain à l'école lui
demander comme amélie c'est cm2 sont les
premiers détenteurs du permis internet
de la ville d'elancourt de classe ont
répondu à l'appel de la commune et il
était important à notre avis de pouvoir
faire une information aux enfants sur
les bonnes pratiques d'internet je
préfère dire les bonnes pratiques
d'internet plutôt que les dangers
d'internet et danger c'est anxiogène et
du coup ils vont plus en servir avec un
guide fourni par le ministère de
l'intérieur
un agent municipal a assuré quatre
séances de formation conclut par un
questionnaire une manière de les
sensibiliser aux différents aspects
d'internet
je pense que c'est important de leur en
parler souvent parce que ils n'en n'ont
pas forcément conscience ils n'ont pas
forcément conscience des dégâts qu'ils
peuvent faire sur leurs camarades
on est en mettant sur internet des
choses pas très sympathique
donc c'est vraiment important qu'ils
soient sensibilisés à tous ces thèmes
est aussi et surtout au thème du
harcèlement sur internet pour l'année
scolaire 2016 2017 la commune souhaite
former de nouveaux agents municipaux
pour sensibiliser des classes
supplémentaires
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien nous recevons au plateau en
plateau par dont laurent carle directeur
du directeur du centre horticole du
tremblay sur mauldre je vais y arriver
mon sort à vous bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors
l'établissement fête cette année ses 70
ans
et oui 70 ans ça se fête effective c'est
un bel anniversaire alors pour rappel
votre centre propose des formations au
collège ou au lycée par apprentissage ou
en formation continue de la 4e au bts
dans les métiers du paysage et de
l'environnement
alors justement il ya un instant on
parlait du baccalauréat des élèves de
votre lycée se prépare vous les
accompagnez c'est un petit peu une
période compliquée pour voir et oui
période compliquée autant pour les
jeunes que pour les familles bien
souvent comme on dit un petit peu stress
il en faut mais pas trop donc beaucoup
d'accompagnement un peu de bachotage des
révisions et puis surtout beaucoup de
pratique pour les mettre en situation
pour qu'il soit fin prêt pour le jour j
cette épreuve spécifique effectivement
pour notamment les épreuves
professionnelles il y à des épreuves de
terrain pour lequel on souhaite que la
météo reste bien sûr au beau fixe
les derniers jours heureusement non et
bien sûr on est de tout coeur avec tous
les établissements qui malheureusement
ont été impactés alors non vous fêté
cette année ses veaux 70 ans
il ya de nombreuses évolutions
concernant les formations est ce que
vous vous formation les différentiels
également alors nous étions au départ
sur les formations de l'horticulture à
partir des années 70 nous sommes partis
sur les formations du paysage et à
partir des de l'année 2007 nous avons
pris également l'orientation des
de la filière de l'environnement donc à
ce jour nous formons les jeunes sur les
métiers du paysage et de l'environnement
nous avons par exemple le bac gestion
des milieux naturels et de la faune et
le bac aménagement du paysage et après
le bts gestion et protection de la
nature
donc effectivement c'est nature
environnement faune flore protection de
l'environnement la nature également bien
sûr tout ce qu'il en découle par rapport
aux relations nature hommes urbanisme
est également bien vivre ensemble
alors quand c'est comment les métiers du
paysage et l'environnement ont évolué
est-ce qu'il ya toujours autant de
demandes de recrutement nous avons à ce
jour notamment sur le département du 78
beaucoup d'offres d'emploi sur le
domaine du paysage et de l'environnement
et il se trouve que c'est une filière
qui mérite d'être connu et qui mérite
d'être beaucoup plus valorisé que ce
qu'elle peut l'être aujourd'hui par
rapport à des élèves qui sont on apprend
celle en formation continue
donc si on apprentis ils recherchent vu
que les chefs d'entreprise prennent
c'est compliqué pour vous les aider à
les accompagner
nous avons une démarche d'accompagnement
mais ça fait également partie de la
formation et on laisse en premier lieu
les jeunes faire des recherches par eux
mêmes aujourd'hui recherche un stage où
ils recherchent un maître
d'apprentissage et de manière
chercheront un emploi ça fait partie
bien sûr de la formation également hélas
pour la rentrée prochaine vous avez dû
certainement à voir les préinscriptions
pour ceux qui vont peut-être passer le
bac ça s'annonce comment alors pour
cette année trois portes ouvertes que
nous avons menées dans de très bonnes
conditions
beaucoup de contacts de famille
notamment via internet mais également le
bouche à oreille ça veut dire que nous
sommes bien connue et reconnue sur le
territoire on se projette assez
sereinement pour la rentrée prochaine
alors vous multipliez les opérations les
initiatives pour vous faire connaître il
ya différents concours on va le but
c'est qu'on parle qu'on parle du duché
ça c'est un petit peu l'idée est surtout
de pouvoir valoriser nos jeunes des
jeunes on les accompagne par
les formations nous les accompagnons sur
les aspects professionnels sur les
aspects éducatifs mais également sur les
savoir-faire sur le savoir-être et quand
on peut être en mesure de pouvoir
valoriser les jeunes et participer à
l'activité et à la valorisation du
territoire dont nous n'hésitons pas et à
ce titre on peut penser au concours des
végétaux on peut penser vous olympiades
des lipides des métiers arrêtez moi il
est inquiète des métiers si on peut
revenir dessus en quoi ça consiste
alors concrètement bas c'est un peu une
journée challenge puisque les jeunes par
binômes ont un sujet à réaliser ils ont
du matériel
ils ont leurs connaissances leurs
compétences leur technicité ils ont un
temps imparti pour réaliser notamment
une scène paysage heure est donc
l'objectif c'est sur la journée ou sur
deux jours de pouvoir réaliser et mettre
dans de bonnes conditions l'ensemble de
la technicité des compétences qu'ils ont
pu apprendre pendant un certain nombre
d'années les siens vos élèves qui s'est
distinguée au concours de la fondation à
truffaut pour un projet avec ça c'est
original
tout à fait et c'est vrai que on
remercie notamment des initiatives
telles que celles ci puisque ça permet
pour des groupes de jeunes et ou pour
des jeunes de façon individuelle de
pouvoir se mettre en avant
travailler et se projeter de fait dans
le métier qu'ils feront par la suite
et là ça consistait notamment sur la
création de deux plans et donc recoupe
un petit peu larchitecture du paysage
activité très intéressante et et ô
combien valorisante pour nos métiers
alors donc là cette année les 70 on
regarde déjà vers le futur pour le chef
il ya le projet confié valent également
un projet d'hébergement ce composant 06
alors compris valent déjà pour préciser
ces campus yvelines alternance et
environnement qui des six volets ce que
nous partageons aujourd'hui le site avec
deux autres centres de formation et à
terme c'est de pouvoir mutualiser ce
site de restructurer une partie de
l'existant et de construire un
hébergement 9 pour pouvoir accueillir
dans d'excellentes conditions
les futurs internes que nous serons
amenés à accueillir sur ses prochaines
décennies
du coup plus d'élèves seront amenés vous
attendez plus d'élèves dans le privé
voilà l'idée c'est de pouvoir bien sûr
valorisé à hauteur de 20 de 15 à 20%
d'augmentation des effectifs quel que
soit d'ailleurs les spécificités des
publicains puisque nous accueillons des
stagiaires de la formation continue des
apprentis mais également des lycéens et
il l'idée c'est de pouvoir répondre à
l'évolution des besoins du territoire et
à ce titre nous ferons bien sûr
également évolué nous ne tranche de
formation et par rapport aux autres il
ya des professeurs qui vont libérer du
coup ça va quoi être complètement une
organisation différente envers telle ou
telle année ça va très prochainement
qu'on peut attendre c'est donc sous
trois quatre ans là donc ça veut dire
que sur l'échéance moyen terme ça c'est
loin mais ça va très vite
donc en termes d'organisation et ben
petit à petit et on prépare
effectivement les équipes à cette
nouvelle organisation
merci beaucoup laurent card est venue
des rssi répondu à nos questions alors
si vous voulez plus de renseignements
sur le centre horticole du tremblay sur
mauldre qu'on appelle le chef n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran et
une dernières informations avant de
refermer ce journal hier nous vous
parlions du concours de la meilleure
baguette des yvelines la maison de la
boulangerie et de la pâtisserie des
yvelines organisé ce concours où 150
concurrents se sont affrontés
le jury a annoncé les résultats
aujourd'hui alors pas de vainqueur parmi
les professionnels des yvelines parmi
les chefs d'entreprise c'est jérôme clé
pas ton patron pardon du pain de chailly
à mantes la jolie qui a été distingué
dans la catégorie des salariés c'est
wilfried marcucci de la boulangerie
fument ou à marigny le roi qui
l'emportent
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis tout de suite
restez avec nous vous avez rendez vous
avec nouradine haguenau pour le cette
fille de société il s'intéressera avec
ses invités à la mobilisation contre la
loi travail et peut-être une possible
sortie de crise je vous retrouve demain
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 2 le
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée